you know what they used to do to guys
like that when they were in a place like
this they'd be carried out on a
stretcher folks I'm gonna stop all over
your face with golf spikes because I'm
gonna win this for the state of
Pennsylvania you cannot be civil with a
political party that wants to destroy
what you stand for what you care about
if politics these days seem especially
ugly that's because they are not even
counting physical attacks on Senator
Rand Paul the shooting of Congressman
Steve Scalise and the punching and
kicking that have become routine at
demonstrations politics are more heated
and divisive than they have been in
years and for good reason
the people who control politics insists
that every piece of legislation every
Supreme Court nomination every midterm
election every minor rule change is
bringing the world one step closer to
the apocalypse using plastic straws
kneeling for the national anthem decade
old tweets there isn't anything we do
anymore that doesn't immediately get
sucked into angry partisan arguments
civility won't return until more of us
channel our inner libertarians and
realize that not all parts of our lives
need to be politicized how do you expect
people to respond when we're told each
day is the beginning of the end of our
way of life that the other side is not
just mistaken but pure evil you are
either complicit in the evil you are
either contributing to the wrong or you
are fighting against it and we're
limited to two parties that represent
fewer and fewer of us the government is
spending more borrowing more and it's
controlling more and more aspects of our
lives for no reason other than pure
political game
if we are fortunate enough to win back
the house and/or the Senate
that's when civility can start again if
civility can't return to politics unless
your team is in charge you're doing it
wrong civility is only going to return
when people stop treating politics as
the only thing that matters and we start
actually shrinking the size scope and
spending of government and give
ourselves some room to breathe that's
especially true if we're stuck with just
two choices who have pledged to screw
the other side over neither Republicans
or Democrats offer a plan where you get
to live however you want which helps
explain why so few of us want to be part
of either
party and why civility won't return to
politics until politicians stop cramming
themselves into every corner of our
lives
[Applause]